it's all about people it's it's people
doing business with people you have to
build those relationships you have to
build that kind of trust
and and you know you're in this uh let's
say in this game
and and the best way to to make it
happen is to always strive for finding
the win-win you know so if you can find
the win-win where the customer is happy
and he gets a win and and you are happy
because you know you obviously won you
got a new customer that's the best way
to achieve success
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opwest hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
this episode is all about databases
microseconds fulfillment
welcome ami
novich general manager of aerospike
israel
he is a technology geek with over 20
years of experience in the world of
databases and is eager to continuously
learn and improve while removing
obstacles out of his way
he is keen to reach success and always
strive to achieve a true win-win and
believes that doing business is all
about the people and finding the shared
road to success
for eight years he's worked for john
bryce and delivered technical database
training for thousands of people
globally following that he founded his
training and services boutique company
and after 10 years he had the
opportunity to kick-start the aerospike
israel entity which has been leading
since 2018.
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
today i'm perfectly fine good morning
thank you for having me i'm i'm great
yourself i'm i'm fantastic thank you
very much for joining me today uh we're
gonna be talking about databases a
little bit of music a little bit about
your own journey and and what you've
learned over there over your
your uh
you know experiences whether it be an
education through john bryce or now at
aerospike and i'd love for you to start
by walking me through
your career a little bit and and start
me off with your entrance to the whole
database world and and i think what i
really want to try to understand is how
do you get to become so passionate about
this topic
well
um
i think uh you know i can say that uh
the fact that i'm today a database geek
you can say
is probably kind of like a coincidence
maybe it was i don't know faith
um so
so when i when i started my journey my
professional journey you'd say on you
know being a high-tech geek it was um
about mid-2000
i'm a little old so like 21 years ago
um i i basically just did a john bryce
training
um that was focused on building a
website you know we're talking about the
year 2000 everyone needs a website
and i did this uh what was used to be
called the webmaster training
and i was basically learning you know
basic programming and creating websites
like html and stuff you know back in the
year 2000
in the end of that
of that course of that training which
was like a three months educational
training
um i got a couple of proposals you know
to be a webmaster for this website and
that website and another and then there
was a one specific uh uh proposal that
was more interesting to me than others
which was to become a john bryce uh
trainer instructor to to actually uh
stay
working for john boss as a as a
technical instructor and then i had to
do my like audition you know the screen
test so i had to deliver something like
a 15 20 minutes of training
and i did a basic html training
like really basic stuff that every kid
can probably do it today
and you know i don't know maybe i was
lucky but one of the guys that was
actually sitting in that room and and
watching me doing that audition he was
leading the database team at john rice
at that point of time and by the end of
that 20 minutes edition he said
i like you i like the way you train i
like the way you deliver you know the
content and everything how you explain
everything i want you to come and walk
for my team and i said okay well what
does it mean what am i going to do that
he said
it's the database team you're going to
learn oracle and sql all this kind of
stuff you know nothing about it leave it
to us we'll learn we'll teach you you
will learn everything will be fine and
like three months later
or maybe four months later at most i was
delivering my first uh oracle database
programming training in in champaign
illinois so it was really it was like
crazy start and and you know the rest is
history so uh that's how i started my
journey with databases and during the
eight years that i was working there
from 2000 2008 i did
i don't know hundreds maybe thousands of
trainings globally all over the world in
obviously in israel of course but also
in the states and in europe and in many
many countries in many many companies
and i got to meet
lots of lots of lots of people and and
many of the database administrators back
in those years that learned oracle or
other database related courses we
probably met at some point of time so
that's where it all started amazing and
so
tell me a little bit about what you
learned
about teaching databases you know in
those eight years because i guess one of
the things that
and and you know i i don't know if it
was socrates or somebody said the best
way to become an expert in something is
to teach it to somebody else right and
and so
what was it like for you those eight
years you're teaching this material
how does how is your relationship
changing with the material as you're
teaching it
so
where it's very hard actually to start
because
it always feels like you have to learn a
lot and then you have to be
better than anyone else that you're
going to teach because you you know you
have to be ready for each and every
question and an example and
and it's a big challenge but i think
that's one of the things that i
you know that is mostly exciting for me
the fact that i know that i have a
challenge and then how i strive to to to
to get to that challenge you know to um
to be in that in that in that place in
my life where i can say okay i made it
and now next challenge so it was a huge
challenge for me and and i think that
you know i learned a lot and and
constantly learning and constantly
getting better is is part of my
day-to-day
and uh you know database is kind of like
i sometimes i need i'm trying to you
know to explain it to people that are
less familiar with the high tech and
technologies and everything it's kind of
like if you if you think about like
something like a car and you need to
drive somewhere that's basically like
the engine
not many people want to know how exactly
the engine walks and how exactly you
know
to fix it and to tune it if it makes you
some you know troubles and stuff many
people just like to go into the car and
drive it maybe you prefer to
um you know learn about the ui how it
how things
look like and and more be at the front
and databases is all about the engine
it's all about you know the
infrastructure and
and it fascinated me because the thing
that you can do with the databases and
and how it can impact
the entire application you know today
fast forward 20 years
later with the world of digital and with
the world of real time
20 years ago we used to talk about
having hundreds of users using the
database at once 100 user maybe a
thousand user wow that's like a big
application can have 1 000 user at the
same time if you look at the gaming
applications today just as an example
you'll find hundreds of thousands of
people using that application at once
and and if you think about things like
paypal and and sony and all those kind
of monsters you'll find millions of
people that are using those kind of
applications at once the databases are
completely in different places than they
used to be like 20 years ago you don't
talk about database from tens or
hundreds of users you talk about
millions of users and databases have
billions of records today numbers that
were not really that relevant 20 21
years ago when i started this kind of
journey so it's really fascinating for
me and constantly learning and getting
better and learning more and more about
the technology and the use cases and and
what are the kind of things that you can
enable that you can empower using your
your database technology
those are the stuff that are really
fascinating i believe and so one of the
things that you also mentioned to me
previously is this idea that of our
expectation in terms of latency and and
the the optimization of databases and
and it's no longer just a it's no longer
just a
and a place where that allows us to
store information now it's actually it
is a critical infrastructure and the
critical part of it is also the fact
that we need sometimes data in
microseconds not in seconds or in
minutes right definitely definitely well
while we used to talk about like second
so i will get my query processed by the
database like in a second while that's
fast today we talk about microseconds so
you know think about an autonomous
vehicle that constantly gets data in
real time it doesn't have a second
to make a decision right why need to go
here or do i need to go there okay think
about
we mentioned a few minutes ago we
mentioned something like paypal a
digital experience you have to
move money from one place to another you
have to do it at real time you don't
have a second to decide if this is a
fraud or if this is a real user that is
actually trying to you know transfer
money from one place to another right
there are plenty of applications that we
are using today especially since you
know everything moved to this to this
piece
um
where every microsecond really makes a
difference every microsecond matters
okay so
you know if you think about those kind
of applications
in in in a second you might have to
check hundreds of different parameters
and make hundreds of decisions whether
you should do this or you should do that
and and you know thinking about uh we
talked about cyber for example thinking
about those cyber
uh um uh examples you don't have a
second to make a decision you have
microseconds where you can need whether
you will need to
you know check plenty of different
parameters and and aspects and make the
right decision
about what is actually going on and what
should i do with this
cyber fraud
game okay just a gaming experience
you're simply just playing on your
on your iphone or android or whatever
you can't really wait a few seconds to
get your scores or to get to the next
level or whatever you just stop using
that game and switch to another game
right or on a website if you want to
purchase something right right so it's a
different world today where we live in
and the databases has to keep up with
those with that kind of demand for for
the users for the throughput for the
latency
and also being uptime
all the time you can't really afford
yourself to be down you know i had a
conversation with with someone about i
don't know like two weeks ago
the database that they were
using
actually caused them a fail a downtime
and and the entire application this is
like a digital application something
that has to be online used for online
trading they were done for like 15 hours
okay that causes you millions of dollars
of losses right so you have to be
constantly up like five nines constantly
up uptime
you have to be global obviously because
it doesn't matter if you are
you know a mobile application that was
developed in ukraine in israel or
wherever it's going to be used globally
hopefully that that's your goal and you
have to support those hundreds of
thousands of millions of users playing
at the same time or using that
application at the same time and also
very very low latencies microseconds
that that matters that that's where we
are today with databases right and so
you know a lot of things that you're
mentioning now
i think are a great segue to your
current position in aerospike your
country manager for israel you've been
there for for quite a few years
previously and you were also the ceo of
of brelix and and db access and
you know with
within aerospike
what are you learning about you know
working with enterprise customers and
how do you instill either a source of
security in terms of the latency because
obviously at the end promises are great
but you know the world is moving more to
to this microseconds there's a it's a
very crowded market and you know it's a
lot of responsibility to go to another
company and say we're going to be
helping you manage your your databases
and and you're going to have to trust us
that we're going to be there for you and
you're not going to lose those millions
of dollars so how do you even
strategically go about thinking through
providing a service like that
so i i think one of the main challenges
today in our market and and
you got it really really perfectly well
you know what exactly we have there in
terms of uh you know throughput latency
all the stuff that we talked about one
of the main challenges is the scale so
you know if we look back at israel as an
ecosystem you know for startups we used
to be called as you probably know the
startup nation right
but if we look at what is going on in
our country in like the last year or two
years it's not really a startup nation
anymore it's a scale-up nation with all
those huge companies that we
we keep hearing the last few only the
last two weeks i think we had last week
we had like three or four companies that
went public like in two days maybe even
in the same day with tabula and and
peony and and whatever you know so many
names
so it's not only that game of the real
time and microseconds the thing we
talked about and like the latency it's
also the scale so many of those
companies started
four years ago seven years ago ten years
ago with a smaller scale but today they
have to cope with huge scales of data
and huge scales of users
and this is you know one of the
biggest challenges
that uh is at least as i said for my you
mentioned the fact that i'm the country
manager for oil spikes so
when i was first introduced to aerospike
i i've been a database guy for many
years as we said and i came from the
relational databases
and when i was first introduced to
aerospike which was in 2016
so okay
it's a database that can do you know
lots of throughput and very low latency
and okay great performance
but the the big thing is the scale
because many databases can work really
fast and really great for like 100
gigabyte of data but what happens when
it's a hundred terabyte of data okay and
and today in israel
uh you know working with companies like
apps flyers working with companies like
iron source working with companies like
platika and cyberis and all those
extremely growing fast companies some of
them are already public some of them
will for sure become public very soon
the scale is there is the main thing so
it's not only you have to be fast and
and great and up but you have to do it
in a scale of like tens and hundreds of
terabytes
and and and that's really you know it's
a huge challenge
uh i don't want to bore you with things
like how exactly you know the database
engine works but let's just say that
the fact that we can optimize the way we
use the hardware gives us the ability to
walk at any scale from gigabytes to
terabytes and and to petabytes even and
basically solve any real-time
any real-time application requirements
where you need high flow put low latency
much much lower footprint server-wise so
it's also easier to manage it and and
this is exactly you know the places
where we shine where we need that
throughput and latency and you need it
at scale so those are and that's
fascinating
i believe that that's what is
encouraging me you know every day to
meet those guys where they have those
you see sometimes it can be a company
with 70 people over 100 people like a
tiny company from israel
somewhere in the center of tel aviv you
know a small startup but their scale is
like hundreds of terabytes of data every
day so that's really yeah
so when you
when you talk about the relationships
with these companies
this trust what have you learned about
building this trust
and conveying it
at the end you know you're working with
enterprises the technology can be great
they're not going in they're not looking
at your hardware and you're not bringing
them into your code base right you have
to form some sort of relationship so
that they they install this trust in you
what did you learn about forming this
trust
with a lot of these clients that you
mentioned
great question so
it's all about relationships it's not
about
you know doing business with brands with
companies with logos
it's all about doing business with
people it's people doing business with
people and and it doesn't matter
if you're a small company a large
company an israeli company a us company
one of the things that i also had to you
know start
uh learning and adjust
as you mentioned i used to work for john
bryce i had my own business that i but i
started and managed for like 10 years
it's different to be part of a
a u.s company you know a corporate which
is global with offices all around the
world but at the end of the day it
doesn't matter if it's us or israeli or
german or you know a huge company uh or
a startup it's all about people it's
it's people doing business with people
you have to build those relationships
you have to build that kind of trust and
and you know you're in this uh let's say
in this game
and and the best way to to make it
happen is to always strive for finding
the win-win
you know so if you can find the win-win
where the customer is happy and he gets
a win and and you are happy because you
know you obviously won you got a new
customer that's the best way to achieve
success i i love it i love this
conversation and um thank you so so much
for coming here i have a few last short
questions that i want to ask not about
databases or about aerospike but about
you and i want to take you back to your
childhood what really what fascinated
you as a kid before you got introduced
to even html or our databases
um
i think three main things it's gonna
it's gonna sound a little maybe four
things three things from school and the
other one is outside of school so
school-wise you know learning-wise it's
going to sound very geeky but i really
liked mathematics
english
and later on when i started learning
computers and that was in in high school
all the others i was like if you look at
my
certification from like high school
you'll see everything is like very much
poor
but those were like the three main
topics that i really liked and and it
also
it worked better for me there you know
comparing to the other stuff that i
learned and did and the other thing is
that um you know many people actually
don't know that but i used to play the
keyboards
so i played the piano in the organ since
like i was six years old
for like 12 years until
the army
and um you know i think also today when
i look at
what i did there in my 12 years there
and and what i did later on is being an
engineer a database gig a high tech geek
there are there are many things that i
can see that you know i did there as a
musician because i was basically you can
say that i was on the on the path to
becoming a professional musician
some of the the friends that i you know
that i played with back then a great
musicians today and some of them are
really famous and very popular and
the kind of creativity that you need in
being a musician is sometimes the kind
of creativity that you need even today
when you are an engineer or you know
where you're developing
programs and writing code
that's one type of creativity that's
another type of criteria but it's the
same kind of creativity that that you
know you can still use it today i'm
still playing the kibo it's just
a different type of keyboard you know
but
i love it i love it and so what inspires
you today as you go about your day today
in aerospike
um
sometimes you know i try to think about
things like role models and stuff like
that but honestly
instead of just saying that you know she
is a role model or he is a moral model
like i i think that in general
as long as you constantly
you know have a challenge in life and
you strive to do your best to learn to
improve and to achieve that challenge
and and the way to do it you the road to
success is full of creating those
relationships and partnerships
working with people it's all about
people like i said before and and
finding the the best shared way to
success
if anyone has that kind of mindset and
the goal and he or she is doing his best
her best to to achieve that that can be
a perfect role whether you're a
politician
uh you know someone like jai lapid for
example he had a challenge a huge
challenge and he put aside his ego and
everything else that he has to do to
achieve that challenge and and and
whether your gal gadot and and she had
her own challenge and she wanted to be
an actress and the best one and you know
being in in in those huge films like
wonder woman and she made it so as long
as you have that challenge in life and
you constantly strive to achieve it and
you're looking for that best shared
partnership way to achieve that win-win
that's a role model for me
and what are three words you would use
to describe yourself
um
i'm a people's people
i'm a people's person
people's person ami
thank you very much michael thanks a lot
it was a pleasure thank you take care